welcome everybody
i am dr uma donna ballen this is the
fourth annual lab roots conference
very excited and our topic today is
about have been cannabis
and my lecture today is cannabis the
global solution
i am at uplifting health and wellness in
cambridge massachusetts today
a little bit about who i am and where i
am
from i am the founder and ceo of global
health and hygiene solutions
established in 2006 with a mission to
promote wellness
and prevent illness
in 2014 i created the clinic uplifting
health and wellness where cannabis
became
part of my toolkit and our mission and
our three words are
educate embrace and empower
registered trademarks are cannabis the
exit drug
and dr uma says
my background i am originally from india
i came to this country in 1970
i did my medical school in new jersey
medical school
in newark new jersey i had done research
there for about 30 years
prior to that as well and i did also my
residency after that at the medical
university of south carolina
in charleston south carolina
in family medicine after i finished that
i came to massachusetts
and did my second life at the harvard
school of public health
i did my master's in public health and
my residency in occupational
environmental medicine
and my fellowship in heavy metals my
mission was about prevention
versus more treatment i am also
a certified medical review officer
and i'm also very proud to say i am
certified and a diplomat
in the american academy of cannabinoid
medicine
and i have been writing recommendations
for cannabis since 2012
initially in the state of washington and
in the state of massachusetts since
2014.
our objectives today are three in
particular
i hope for you to understand what is
cannabis
the difference between hemp and
marijuana what is the endocannabinoid
system
and how does cannabis work with the ecs
or the endocannabinoid system what is
the role of cannabis both
in the medical and industrial products
and why
i call it a global solution
pope francis said the earth
our home is beginning to look like an
immense pile of
filth a very sad statement
and truly a problem that we are facing
today
locally and globally my hopes are
to give you a solution and why i call
cannabis
the global solution
our world has been contaminated
by pollution some of which is natural
emissions
from the world around us and what we as
humans have created
the impact of this pollution has been
not only in our local sites but it has
been carried
through the air through the water and
contaminated
our waters and also our soil
this process a solution has withstood
time
and what we understand is that it has
affected the air that we breathe
the water that we drink
and the animals that also cohabitate
with us
what we realize is the water
the smaller animals which are consumed
by the larger animals
and the larger food chain that we
consume
ultimately contamination and poisons
that we are exposed to in our day-to-day
life
and not only today over time and what
the earth
and what the world faces
the health effects of pollution from
air pollution and water pollution
are immense it has impacted
multiple systems respiratory illnesses
creating bacteria parasites and
chemicals that we see
that impact that cardiovascular
illnesses
gastric illnesses even cancer
that has been caused we see
air pollution creates carbon monoxide
which impacts particulate matters are
ozone which in fact impacts nerve damage
contamination from lead from volatile
organic compounds
which can affect our skin and cause
irritation
just to mention a few our air
our water and our soil are contaminated
causing multiple illnesses throughout
the world
what we see is this has impacted
every endocrine system
we productive system our testes and our
ovaries
in our pancreas affecting
digestion and also diabetes and our
blood sugars
our thyroid gland our parathyroid gland
impacting calcium
temperature control hearts
our kidneys our adrenal glands our
gastric system
our pituitary gland every system
has been impacted and been disrupted
what is also happening is our world is
aging
not just here but throughout the world
our elder population is growing
and will exceed our younger population
expectations
and what it has done is also created
pandemics
throughout the world we have faced this
as civilization
will continue dating back to black death
the plague smallpox
the spanish flu hiv
and more recently covet 19.
the impact program 19 has had
in compared to our population that
exists today
over 7 billion compared to back in the
day
of less than a billion people
as population grows we may and
will expect other pandemics and
epidemics to impact us
so how shall we prepare
dr uma says that cannabis is for people
pets the planet for peace
and for profit and to me
your health and wellness is your profit
today cannabis
is in schedule 1 along with heroin
lsd and ecstasy and has been there
since 1970 when the control substance
act
was created but history tells us that
doctors
had the liberty to write a prescription
and cannabis was listed in the
pharmacopoeia
from 1850 to 1942.
yes in the united states pharmacokia
and companies like park davis squibb
eli lilly were producers of these
medications
we also know cannabis was a treatment
for neuralgia
tetanus typhus cholera rabies and
dysentery and guess what
alcoholism and opioid addiction
were treated with cannabis not to cause
us
it treated doubt it treated convulsive
disorders
tonsillitis insanity yes
treatment of insanity not the cause of
insanity
we also know that william o'shaughnessy
first
learned about this plan yes from india
where i am originally from
he had learned about this plant from the
aeratic doctors
in calcutta he had seen how they had
used it
for all the elements that i had just
mentioned
and yes he brought the knowledge to
europe
and ultimately to the united states
where it was listed as medicine
what we know today is that nobody
nobody in the whole world has ever
overdosed or causing the death from
cannabis
taco alcohol
caffeine aspirin and
even water can kill you but cannabis
cannot
what we know is that cannabis was
food fuel fiber
paper and medicine it was replaced
by synthetic synthetic synthetic
synthetic synthetics
and these all have names the hearse
the dupont the rockefeller carnegie and
melon and yes these names are known to
us today
they were the root cause for what was
created
from racism and politics and the
ultimate greed
that put this plant into prohibition
in the 1600s you were mandated
to grow this plant you even fail jail
sentence if you did not grow it
in the 1850s it was medicine
it was then in the 1800s
that things changed and statements like
reefer makes [ __ ] they
repeat that again reefer makes [ __ ]
think that they are as good as white men
i wish i could show you what a small
marijuana cigarette can do
to our degenerating residents
or mexican population they were
referring to
racism and politics where the underlying
cause
of why cannabis was put into prohibition
marijuana the most violent drug in the
history of mankind
i like to say that it is one of the
safest
drugs among the most important plants
and i like to refer
to it as cannabis as it should be
cannabis is in schedule 1 along with
heroin
lsd and ecstasy and it has been there
since 1970 today drugs are classified
into five classes
and cannabis continues to be illegal but
today we have states where cannabis can
be used as medicine
and can be written as a recommendation
by clinicians and health care providers
for patients
what we know is that cannabis was
available
in a form of tinctures in multiple
forms including asthma cigarettes
yes asthma cigarettes and what was
in these cigarettes but cannabis
cannabis
was used for the treatment of asthma as
one inhaled it inhalation caused
bronchodilation vasodilation
brought down the inflammation
it was books and magazines created
to change the stigma
reaper madness devil's harvest
but we know the truth today cannabis is
much safer than many of the drugs and we
are
facing an opioid epidemic as well
in the words of dr reynolds he writes in
the first issue of the lancet
when pure and administered carefully
cannabis is one of the most valuable
medicines we possess and yes today we
are learning about
more of it
dr raphael mashulim in israel who is
known as the grandfather of cannabis
first started to work with cannabis and
discovered
thc is what he denotes as the
psychoactive component
of the cannabis plant i like to refer to
it as the
intoxicating component in 1992
he also discovered the first
endocannabinoid
endo meaning within our body and
cannabinoid meaning it has something to
do with cannabis
he named it an undermine from the roots
of the sanskrit word meaning ananda
eternal bliss supreme joy
i as a clinician have learned about
the respiratory system the cardiac
system the reproductive system
the lymphatic system in multiple
multiple systems
but i had never ever ever learned about
the
endocannabinoid system
it was not until 2010 when my mom
had seen a tv program about how cannabis
was being used in
israel and i could still hear her saying
they're using
gunja i've been lined into the bedroom
and it was being used for copd asthma
lung cancer and ptsd did not compute
it was then when my love and my passion
brought me to understand that this
beautiful system
existed
i never got to use this plant for my
mother but it was
after her death in january 2012
that i decided that education
and to change the stigma regarding
cannabis
and for the world to know about the
endocannabinoid system
became my mission and i do it through
education
dr dimaggio explains the endocannabinoid
system in five beautiful words
he states that the endocannabinoid
system is meant for us to relax
eat sleep forget and protect
i describe the endocannabinoid system in
one word
life
if any one of those words
if we can relate to if your muscle is
constantly twitching
or if it just doesn't move enough if you
eat too much
obesity if you don't eat enough anorexia
if you sleep too much depression if you
don't sleep enough pts
and i like to leave the d off we are not
disorders or diseases
if you forget too much alzheimer's
if you don't forget enough pts
if your body overreacts it creates
autoimmune diseases
if it does not react enough it creates
diseases where you are
immunocompromising
so remember the words and the mantra
relax
eat sleep forget and protect
the endocannabinoid system is evolved
from a c square to what we have in
humans today
over 600 million years
what we know is that the endocannabinoid
system works with receptors
throughout the body two well
receptors that have been studied have
been cb1
which is primarily in the brain and cb2
primarily in the immune system
but we've learned that there's multiple
other receptors
all through various systems
what is very unique about the
endocannabinoid system is that
it is very analogous to the nervous
system
we synaptic to postsynaptic
neurotransmitters like dopamine and
serotonin
are created in presynaptic and they are
released and they bind
to the postsynaptic endocannabinoids are
unique in that
they are made in the presynaptic and
released
and bind to the receptors in the
postsynaptic
it is a unique retrograde mechanism
ultimately to bring about homeostasis
balance ease
if you are not at ease you are at this
ease and we have come up with multiple
world
words to describe these diseases
which all ultimately have to do with
inflammation
when we talk about cannabinoids we
talked about
endocannabinoids anandamide
which was first discovered by dr
michelin
and in the first drop of bresna a baby
consumes and then the mind mimics
thc and that is why it works so
beautifully
with the cb1 receptors and cb2 receptors
it helps the baby to relax and to eat
and get its nourishment
phytocannabinoids are cannabinoids
derived from plants and we are talking
about the cannabis plant
the cannabis plant we have identified
over 150 different cannabinoids
synthetic cannabinoids are cannabinoids
that are
made in the lab one of the oldest
synthetic cannabinoids that we know
about is merino
which is a synthetic form of thc
one of the newest synthetic cannabinoids
that we we're aware of
and made them a lot which uses cbd
is epidiolex
the endocannabinoid system is involved
with every
system in the immune system
in the central nervous system in the
gastroenterology system
gastroenter and we repeat that again
central nervous system gastrointestinal
system
hormones bones or metabolism
in every system that we have
what i provide is helping people
understand
today that cannabis is a safe
alternative and should be offered as a
choice
to multiple prescription and
over-the-counter medications
our people are facing multiple diseases
i used to call it the party pack of 5 as
a family physician
diabetes hypertension something for
reflex
something for anxiety something for
their
sleep as well diabetes
hypertension cholesterol reflux
anxiety or depression what we want
people to understand
is that there can be drug work
interactions and how
metabolism varies due to consumption
if one inhales it versus ingesting it
or even topically understanding that
when you
inhale it it goes through the lungs and
why
you feel the effects much more quickly
and rapidly
versus ingesting it goes through the
liver it must be absorbed
in the liver it gets converted from nine
desolder
to 11 hydroxy a much more protein
component which lasts also longer
we explain to our patients how cannabis
works
the mechanisms of action we know that
cannabis
works as a bronchodilator
it impacts nausea
it is able to help with spasticity it
brings
down the intraocular pressure why it's
used for treatment
of glucoma respiratory issues chronic
pain
spasticity and the list goes on and on
[Music]
when it comes to cancer i feel very
strongly
when the diagnosis of cancer is made
cannabis
must be included as part of the
treatment protocol
we know that cannabis works in four very
specific
properties cannabis works with the
cancer cell
not with the healthy cells it impacts
the cancer cells
in more specific ways does not let the
cancer cells multiply
anti-proliferative does not let the
cancer cell spread
anti-metastatic does not let the blood
supply
continue anti-agenesis
and causes self-depth also known as
apoptosis
we know that cannabis is two times more
stronger
than hydrocodone cannabis is 20 times
anti-inflammatory property of aspirin
and aspirin people can lead to death
we know also that people suffer
from what is known as clinical
endocannabinoid deficiency
dr ethan russo has identified this with
migraines
fibromyalgia ibs i have seen this in my
own practice
treatment and supplementing with
cannabinoids helps
and remove these illnesses and helps
people improve their quality of life
we also know that patients that suffer
from traumatic brain injuries
cannabis can also prevent the worsening
of these symptoms
and can also be used in the prevention
of complications from traumatic brain
injuries
yes complications and prevention of
traumatic brain injuries
we also know that it is used for pts
patients
our veterans have suffered with it and
so many other people suffer with it
even today due to clothing many people
are suffering
from post traumatic stress
the modes of administration can vary
from individual
and your choices inhalation can be
combusted
or vapor it is a quick onset and greater
viability
topicals can be applied with no
intoxicating effects
lotions creams and bones transdermals
can also be applied but they can have
some
effects in our body since it can be
absorbed
suppositories that can be used vaginally
or rectally oral administrations
under the tongue or ingested liquids
strips capsules
tinctures and the lister goes on and on
edibles in the form of candies and foods
and yes these are a longer duration
and can also have a longer effect as
well
there's also new beverages that are
created with and without alcohol
my youngest is four in my clinic and my
eldest is 98 so we have
a variety of options that we see
dr uma says that we are facing an
opioid epidemic in people on multiple
problems
and this is a very safe solution
cannabis is not for everyone yet
it should be a first line option and not
the last resort
i please ask everybody please
open your hearts you don't need to use
this medicine
but you know somebody that can benefit
from it open your mind because we all
have an endocannabinoid system and as
clinicians
and patients this opens doors for better
communication and a better relationship
when it comes to the use of cannabis i
like to use the word
titrate versus dose because cannabis is
a form of personalized medicine
and titrate means a little bit at a time
dosing is a very pharmaceutical word and
it means that you're going to get the
same amount
every time that is not the truth always
with cannabis
so i like to use the word titrate dr uma
has
three rules rule number one always
hydrate before you meditate why because
cannabis
is a dehydrant dry mouth dry throat and
these are some of the side effects that
people can have
start out low or very low and slowly
titrate
up or down and always have food on board
why because cannabis causes your blood
sugar to drop
which can cause you to feel anxious and
we don't want that so make sure that you
have food on board
and the third and most important rule
write it down
journal because it's all about you and
your experience
and how each time it can be a little bit
different
so it's important to write things down
it's called total healthcare thc and the
three words
are educate embrace and empower
i'm very proud to say all of our
patients know about the endocannabinoid
system
we embrace cannabis as a safe
alternative
and we empower our patients to have a
better quality of life
the medical benefits that we see from
cannabis is
an option to relieve chronic pain
and yes it does improve lung capacity
it helps patients lose weight and for
others that need to gain weight it helps
them as well
it helps regulate and even prevent
diabetes it fights cancers
and the four properties that i've
discussed earlier it helps treat
depression
it helps promises hope for patients that
have autism
not only for the individuals but also
for the families
caring for individuals with autism it
helps regulate
seizures it helps mend our bones
it helps with adhd and add it's a
viable treatment for glaucoma it helps
it helps alleviate anxiety it helps slow
down alzheimer's diseases
it helped the pain of arthritis
it helps with pts symptoms my patients
with multiple sclerosis
have been able to use cannabis as their
only medication
and have been able to cope and be able
to put their
illnesses into remission it helps with
my patients
with hepatitis c for not only the
treatment but also to
help cope with the symptoms along with
the
effectiveness of their other treatments
inflammatory bowel disease
ibs ibd patients with multiple symptoms
from constipation to diarrhea cannabis
is sometimes the only thing that is
helping these people
it helps our patients with their tremors
the parkinson's
and yes it is a viable option for the
treatment
of patients that suffer from alcoholism
in my children with autism i truly
believe
this must be offered to them as an
option
there's been lots of reports and lots of
research
so please no more should we say that
there is not enough research
please google or go to www.pubmed.gov
there's lots and lots of information
there's lots and lots of studies
and more to be done we know in the
united states
where cannabis is available and
accessible
there's been a 25 reduction
in opioid deaths in studies
patients prefer cannabis as a substitute
to opioids if it's available my seniors
are becoming very sassy these days they
prefer it
and 90 plus percent of our elderly
prefer this versus their other
prescription meds and they're able to
lower their meds as well
in 1970 what started out
as a controlled substance act which put
cannabis
into prohibition and keeps it there has
made some changes
in 2014 the agricultural act was passed
when obama was president
in december 2018
it went into law when president trump
was in office
cannabis what we know
belongs to the family of cannabisia
the genus cannabis sativa and their
three species cannabis sativa
cannabis indica and cannabis morales
the two well studied and most commonly
spoken about
are cannabis sativa and cannabis indica
i like to explain sativa as
starts with the letter s i think of
sunshine more uplifting
indica i think of the letter i and
insomnia
more sedating but these are just
classifications
most of them are a hybrid and they'll
have properties of a sativa
or an indica
what we know is the difference
between hemp and marijuana what is
it man-made
the difference is based on the
percentage
of a component known as 2009
thc the intoxicating component
in cannabis if it is
less than point three percent
again less than or equal
to point three percent
it is considered as hemp if it is
greater
than 0.3 percent
delta 9 thc it is considered marijuana
ultimately it's all cannabis folks
it's a sideline a line that we have
created
in some countries that is this is up to
one percent
i like to use the analogy when we look
at sisters
and cannabis we've got lemon limes and
oranges
but we break it down into sour or sweet
when it comes to cannabis they've broken
it down based on
the delta nine thc
the three species as i mentioned sativa
more taller leaner and thinner leaves
versus the sativa
more bushier thicker leaves and rooted
alice a combination in between
year
what we understand is that this
beautiful plant
cannabis has multiple multiple
components
we've learned about cannabinoids
flavonoids and
turpenoids the terpenes
are what give it the aroma the
flavonoids
is what give it the colors and the
cannabinoids
are the components that work with our
beautiful receptors
in our body
the diagrams here on the left by richard
rose
explains how in the different forms
of cannabis from when it's in the raw
form
when it is heated or dried the different
cannabinoids that we have identified
and much more to learn the common
cannabis terpenes that we've learned
about limonene
pinene merchant linole and cambroni
these are all different types of
terpenes
we see that how it has an impact
as an anti-anxiety anti-depressant
for asthma anti-inflammation
and yes for chronic pain insomnia
and the list goes on and on
what we understand is that each of these
terpenes
can also be reintroduced and be
combined with various types of
cannabinoids in different ratios
to have different impacts to treat
different illnesses
and diseases
we've learned about cvn cbc
cbd cbg thc
thcb and these are just a few of the
cannabinoids
and cbd which has been around and much
more readily accepted since it has been
non-intoxicating products
comes in three forms it can come from
hemp derived it can come from what is
known as marijuana or synthetically made
but the cbd can vary in how it is
produced
with different products we are also
learning about
new cannabinoids thcp and
cbdp we're understanding
how these cannabinoids are creating the
intoxicating effects
also properties as far as the
anti-inflammatory
and the anti and carcinogenic
ways that we can use it for for
treatment for
cancer patients as well much more to
learn
what we understand is that this
beautiful plant
every part of this plant from the seeds
to the flower to the herd every portion
and the roots can be used for some
purpose
the entire plant can be created
for chemicals and also cleaning agents
to sell fluids for abrasives the stock
the fiber
different types of diapers fabrics
handbags
we know paper can be created
much more lasting and more preservable
building materials that we have fiber
boards
all the components that are used in
building that can be toxic
can be replaced with the materials
created from the herd
of the hemp plant the hemp seed
can be used for nutrition food
oils bombs cosmetics
medicine arts
seed cake and food extracts can be made
isolates and the list goes on and
on and on
cannabis for our livestock imagine a
world if our animals
were fed hemp the animals themselves
would not suffer the illnesses
of inflammation we then would not be
secondary consumers
of our chickens the pork the beef that
we consume
the inflammation in the animals we then
consume it
ultimately creating inflammatory
diseases
our animals our pets are fed the
byproducts of these animals
imagine where their lives and the
illnesses that we can prevent
for our pets and our livestock
what we know is that everything plastic
can be made from him and plastic
made from hemp is biodegradable yes
biodegradable we can leave this planet
better
than how we found it the us could save
around 4 billion trees
per year if we switch back to using him
from paper instead of timber
it was known as a billion dollar crop
imagine where our world would be
henry ford had built a car that ran
and fueled on him
imagine the world had it not changed due
to the tyrants
rehearsed the dupont the rockefeller the
carnegies and mountains
the health and wellness of our world
today with legalization
the profit and yes
climate change we are facing
a huge problem that impacts all of us
today and the future of man
and the world that we live in and we
have a solution
and food one of my favorites
one serving three tablespoons gives you
10 grams of protein 21 amino acids
and nine of them are essential it's one
of the most hypoallergenic
items it helps with fiber
it's got omega-3s it's got the perfect
omega-3 omega-6 ratios
it's good for our mind for our muscles
for our body
and every part of this plant the hemp
hearts can be used
the hemp seeds also provide us with
vitamin
e magnesium potassium
manganese and so many other components
which also help as an antioxidant and
anti-inflammatory
what we know is that hemp has multiple
facets that it can be used for
when compared to wheat and corn
it produces eight point times 8.5 tons
of material per hectare per year and
produces 25 tons
oil from palm takes five years before
it fruits wood trees to 50 to 100 years
have matures in four months and it could
be harvested three times per year
usual fibers one acre hemp equals
unusable fibers for four acres of wood
and two acres of cotton hemp is
naturally a hearty plant
pest resistant it needs no pesticides
to cultivate hemp is also drought
resistant
and biofuel step field burns cleaner
it has four times the biomass and
eight times the methanol potential
compared to our current
mainstream biofuel mass that we use
today
compared to corn hemp was be planted
in just six percent of the continental
americas it can be sustainably supply
demand for gas and fuel for the whole
country
in the words of henry ford
i'm going to repeat that again why use
up the forest which were
centuries in the making and the
onlines in which required ages to lay
down
if we can get the equivalent of forest
and mineral products
in an annual growth of the hemp fields
henry ford
purifier hemp is a natural unique
ability
to detoxify the land where it is planted
on
it can absorb the leftover forest on
farmland
after the poultry fertilizers it can
absorb
other harmful substances have planted
in chernobyl and russia for due to the
contamination
and even in japan after
its incidence is there
and this plastic conventional plastics
can be replaced
with cannabis i.e him
it's biodegradable and much less
harmful substances are released in the
process of making this
currently car companies like audi and bm
chrysler are you looking into these as
alternatives as well
campus construction material hemp fiber
mixed with some of the bonding agents
can create
hemp cream hemp cream is a building
bricks
lighter than normal bricks concrete is
fire retardant
one cubic meter and peppery will absorb
165 kilograms of co2
over time and fibers can be turned into
wall
insulation
hemp homes are healthy fire and pest
resistant
no termites vapor permeable breathable
natural permanent material preventing no
off-gassing
no molds no termites no dry rot
and clean indoor air
tampa's antimicrobial we know
that if hemp could have been available
now with
all the mass and materials that have
been discarded
if this could have been used as the
microfiber material
imagine where it could be it can be used
in
sheets in the hospital in your bedding
in your homes
it can prevent the contaminations from
what we know
from bacteria as well
cotton fibers are short fibers one to
two millimeters
hemp fibers are meters long four to five
meters
it's stronger than cotton
strauss was originally creative with him
it's much softer and warmer and water
resistant than cotton
it has high insulatory factors
it keeps you cool when needed and keeps
you
warm in those cold nights
hemp will reduce pesticide pollution
reduce soil erosion and it will help
restore
our soil it will produce biodegradable
plastics
it will absorb the lethal metal it will
produce inhale
inexhaustible biofuel it will reduce our
carbon emission
impact and reduce deforestation
what's the differences that have been
cut
as we said it can impact our water our
soil
less pesticides impact our land
and ultimately much stronger
dr uma says cannabis cares it provides
choices alternatives there's plenty of
research and yes more needs to be done
but the research is there education is
very
important about the stigma and the
endocannabinoid system
and yes it provides solutions
receptors are made for contact compounds
we produce
let me repeat that again receptors are
made for compounds that we produce
not because there is a plant out there
in the words of raphael mushulum
cannabis works no doubt about it
it works essentially every disease
that we investigate
the endocannabinoids system is involved
i am an educator an activist
and an advocate and i fight for my
patients
and my healthcare providers
let me repeat this again make the most
you can of the indian hemp seed the hemp
may be
sown anywhere george washington
hemp is the first necessity to the
wealth and protection of our country
thomas jefferson
hemp will be the future of mankind or
there won't be a future
jackhammer lincoln let me repeat that
again
two of my favorite things are sitting on
the front porch smoking a piper sweet
hemp
and playing my homework harmonica
abraham lincoln
i could not find a single confirmed
overdose death
in the words of sanjay gupta
dr uma says cannabis is for people
pets the planet for peace and profit
and your profit is your health and
wellness
the pillars that i fight for and look
forward to
is to seeing legalization throughout the
world i want to see laboratory
standards so that we can have a label to
identify cannabinoids terpenoids
the flavonoids also for testing of
pesticides heavy metals and
contamination
i want to see cultivation be able to be
even in your own backyard
multiple products can be created one
that can suit
all of our societies for humans and for
pets
education is the key the stigma
regarding canvas must be changed
and the world must know about the
endocannabinoid system
and we do it through education cannabis
is for health and wellness locally and
globally
that's what i say
i am dr uma donovan at
upliftinghealthandwellness.com
i say safety first do no harm our phone
number
is 508-444-2324
and remember cannabis is an entrance to
a better quality of life
and exit from pharmaceuticals narcotics
alcohol and
nicotine reach one
teach ten teach one reach 10.
please pass the message and the
information that you have learned today
i thank you all i thank everyone
that have been here listening to this
and look forward to your questions
look forward to helping in any way i can
and remember
cannabis is a global solution
thank you namaste